Eric and diashimier says he couldn't
bury his 78 year old mother after she
was hacked to death with machetes
fighters from the M23 armed group
attacked his village last week in
eastern Democratic Republic of Congo
my mum left home to go on farm and
suddenly the M23 appeared and killed her
our little brother witnessed it and came
to tell us we didn't go there because we
feared if they're killing an old woman
then they'll be killing young people
like us as well
Eric's among tens of thousands of people
who fled their homes in recent days this
camp on the outskirts of the city of
Goma is their new home
we went up into the hills to see where
they've come from we accompanied an army
General who was visiting commanders near
the front line most of the people that
live around here have fled the homes and
the shops are empty they've been taken
over by soldiers who've turned this
Village into a base
and here they're looking across at their
enemy on that distant Hillside
the slopes here are steep the terrain
makes it very difficult for anyone to
attack or defend
the armies lost waves of territory to
M23 in the last four months many
Congolese are questioning why the
government hasn't done more to support
its forces
m23s rapidly grown stronger it denies
committing atrocities that it's
frequently accused of its Fighters carry
Rwandan Army equipment and Rwandan
soldiers have been photographed among
them Rwanda denies supporting them
this is not M23 it's the Rwandan Army
and you should know that M23 is not only
with the Rwandan Army but it's also
supported by other groups operating
within Congo
[Music]
U.N investigators rights groups and
residents all say Congo's forces have
collaborated with armed groups to fight
against M23 Congo's government denies it
rwanda's accused Congo of hiring foreign
mercenaries Congo's government says it's
hired former French soldiers as military
instructors we need some extractor and I
think those who are working with them
it's a group of what we call in France
francaise they are well known they come
to give some instruction to our military
it's simple
further up in these Hills are koltan
mines that earn vast sums for whoever
controls them
the people who lived here farming the
slopes and now camped in The Valleys
hoping somebody will bring them food
there's been conflict here on and off
since the 1990s
now it's intensifying once again Malcolm
Webb Al Jazeera kingi Democratic
Republic of Congo